ladies and gentlemen
dear friends i offer today
my warmest congratulations to mr
ranjitshin
diesely from india upon winning the 2020
global teachers prize in austria
we have a saying namely wiesen ismart
that means knowledge is power
knowledge is therefore the basis for
empowerment
whereas excellent teachers provide
excellent support to their students
ranjitin's story i hope i pronounce his
name correctly
is truly inspirational when he became a
teacher
he had few resources and little support
only
but he was still able to transform
the quality of education in his
community thanks to ranjit sindh his
students
are able to learn in their own language
they have developed the key skills
they will need for the future namely
communication creativity
and real world problem solving
ranjitin's story shows us
the real difference that one teacher can
make
and i know and you know that there are
thousands more teachers just like
ranchichins
around the world today
the world is coming together to
congratulate
ranjitjin for winning the global teacher
prize
but we are also paying tribute to the
hard work
and sacrifices of teachers
everywhere today it is more
important than ever to celebrate the
difference
a good teacher can make
a good future for all of you for all
teachers
for all pupils and thank you for your
attention
you